so welcome to the last session on the
first other methods in optimization so
after this after this talk we will have
a lunch break and it would be one more
talk like the last top of the
interdepartmental such as right after
the after lunch so the speaker is reza
al razaaq bali from us before washington
and we will talk about interesting
connections between first other methods
and online of these issues I thank you
very much pretty lucky last darkness so
you've seen a lot of fish stuff that I
may be using
during those doggie sniffing start so we
all know what optimization is about a
problem it's got some data and it's got
some variable excuse me in the project
microphone
sorry okay
that's better and you've got some data
and some variables and you probably go
and apply some iterative method to solve
your optimization problem let's call
that offline optimization when you cut
all the data beforehand in the online
setting things may be different so in
the online optimization setting I
consider here you have this notion of
time at each time step T a new variable
comes to you and the data associated
with that variable also is removed to
you the onion algorithm has to assign a
value to that variable and the catch is
that at time t plus 1 when new data is
revealed to you you cannot go back and
change the assignment you previously
made and you have to make the assignment
without knowing what's coming in the
future because by the definition future
happens in the future so the metric that
is used in literature for gauging how
good and on an algorithm is performing
is one of them is competitive ratio now
I'm using metric in a local form not in
the mathematical metric sense so and
that is defined as the ratio of the
objective achieved by your online
algorithm to the offline optimal
so in order to set the notation and have
some general problem we can work with
let's consider this problem facing the
online/offline
form you're trying to maximize the
function sigh your variables are the
sixties and these axis can be vectors
and you have this local constraints on
them that requires the next C to be in
some set of t so the constraints are
local but these variables are coupled
together because your objective is sigh
applied to the sum of x DS and let's
make this assumption that size is a
concave function and to make things
beautiful a nice that map's the cone K
to the real numbers and the cones that
are really of interest or the positive
semi-definite cone and non negative
Orton and FTS let's assume that their
comics compact sets so the entire
problem is a convex problem the
maximizing a concave function subject in
the online setting the on an algorithm
knows what size is beforehand so that's
an information that it has and then at
time T and there is an adversary that
gives the algorithm F T and now the
algorithm has to assign a value to X T
choose X T in F T basically and once
that assignment was made at time T plus
1 same thing happens with F T plus 1 and
XT plus 1 and this contains quite a few
online
problems that people consider in
literature it may not contain some other
even classical ones quiet but quite a
few problems that people considered it
can be written in this format at least
they're convex relaxation many of them
actually unpause supporting any question
on the basic set up so here's an example
of such a problem that's the AdWords
problem introduced by meta in 2007 and
now it's a generalization of online
bipartite matching so suppose you are a
search engine
alright like Google and there are a
couple of advertises the number of them
is fixed and so people search some
something so they enter some query when
a query comes based on what I dig and
the keywords in that query some of the
advertisers bid on it because they want
their ad to be shown to this user and
you know Google has paid a couple of
hundred million dollars that block so
adblock doesn't block the ads of Google
anymore so the this is really of
practical importance and so if you want
to map it to the notation of the
previous slide when Akua comes and
advertisers bid on it it's like you you
just said that is given by adversary has
the bids on it so this is the bit of
advertiser one on query one and this is
the just the first standard basis vector
sign of victor of vector in the standard
basis of RN and this is the bit of acid
as a 2 on a query 1 ah that should be
advertised a 4 on query 1 and this is
just a vector there is all 0 the
description of the fourth entry which is
1 and so forth and so you may also put a
0 vector here to give the algorithm the
Liberty to not even show to choose 0
meaning that you don't pick any idea the
online algorithm picks one of the ads
which is the quality of setting x1 equal
to this w1 Eve on this game or this
procedure continues and it's an online
procedure once you make a decision you
cannot go back and change it so what's
the objective whose objective advertises
objective now the customer objective the
people who are searching no that's not
the objective the objective is search
engine search engine wants to maximize
its revenue and so when these guys bid
on it and if the Madonna and a query and
if the ad is shown they pay equal to
that bit to the search engine but the
catch is that the advertisers have a
limited budget say they have a daily
limited budget so and the search and you
knows that
alright that's then the utility or the
revenue of the search engine for each
advertiser it's got this function side I
which goes up linearly up
the budget of advertiser I and then
flattens meaning that at this point
assigning any picking any odd by that
advertiser is not gonna end up
generating revenue by the search for the
search engine and so your entire utility
is this function it is called the entire
thing just capitals I applied to the
some of these X's which have the bits on
them
a closely another place you had the
world online is online learning also
some people call this online
optimization but I'm not going to do
that in stock and you people were
present in social talk they were
introduced to the concept of online
learning if they were not before and in
that setting what happens is that the
algorithm chooses the online act and
chooses a vector by T in some set D and
then once that victory was chosen the
adversity reveals the lost function and
the algorithm incurs the loss of L T by
T the metric in that setting is
something called regret the way you
gauge the performance of an algorithm
and that's the loss accumulated by the
algorithm during the EMA step of the
this sequential process - the loss of
the best decision so that's the one
fixed best decision you could have made
and put that minimizes the sum of the
loss all the losses and one algorithm
that can be used for example in this
setting is follow the regularized leader
algorithm which is similar to do all
averaging of Nesterov it picks YT plus 1
so it's say you have progress up to time
T now you have to pick YT plus 1 and the
as the minimizer of this inner product
which is the inner product of I with all
the gradient of your previous losses
plus a regularizer alright and so here
you have to go find a regularizer
that gives you a good regret for example
people find a proper regularizer that is
a strongly convex enough to get a 1 over
to get a square root M regret so all
right sounds similar to the previous
problem that I mentioned but it's also
different what is the connection
and how these things relate now so I try
to go with these things during this talk
and a little bit further but before I go
any further I want to point to fact that
first of all on an opt-in on an
algorithm is a big part in CS Tyrian
there's plenty of work done in it if you
are like me if you are from continuous
optimization like me you probably will
enjoy reading those results in
literature where they introduced and the
alloys their online algorithm as a
primal-dual algorithm and a very
fundamental work has been done on these
online primal dual algorithms for
various online problems by Sophie Neve
bookbinder camo Jane by Nikhil Devin or
by OSA and many other people and now if
one wants to start learning more about
online algorithms I guess these are very
good places to start reading on
relationship of this type of
relationship to regret in the last few
years a couple of work has been done on
different settings the worst case
analysis or random permutation analysis
interesting work by Devin or we did
something in the around same time on
random permutation and then after that
on the board case analysis and so in
this remaining 45 minutes I only get to
do very small introduction basically to
this area Anna
so and this is what I'm gonna do we're
gonna try to go over the worst case
analysis competitive ratio analysis of
greedy algorithm applied to that online
problem I first introduced and through
that analysis we see the connection
through the introduction of the
algorithm and the analysis we see the
connection to the regret setting and
then at the end depending on time we go
over this idea of a smoothing or
designing regularization to move further
from greedy algorithm and get better
come to ratio bounds of course in online
optimization greedy is usually just the
performance of greedy is the baseline
you have to beat it you have give better
algorithms but to understand connections
to regret setting it's good to go over
the analysis of the greedy first any
question
so I mentioned primal-dual and we want
to look at primal doing analysis the
connection to with regret is with what
we do becomes obvious when you write the
tool so let's just see what's the do all
of the original problem we wrote and
just in case you forgot the original
problem the original problem was write
maximize this subject to XT being s I
was concave so the primal problem was a
maximization the dual is going to be a
minimization of course and it has two
parts the first part is the kind you get
outside so if you were in Lauren's of
stock you saw the definition of
conjugate here my side was concave when
I started so this is the definition of
concave conjugate it's you can't get
conjugate at some point why let me just
explain over the picture you have your
function sites the blue care and then
you have a just draw a linear function
here which is the inner product of I
with you U is your variable Y is the
slope and look at where the distance
between these two in terms of function
value is maximized so that distance is
going to be or that difference in
function value is going to be the
negative of your conjugate and then you
have for each one of these individual
constraints on x over here on the board
you have a support function dual which
is defined as a the value of support
function is achieved is the maximum of
the linear function over the set F T and
people who are more familiar with the
concept of conjugate they know that this
is basically the conjugate function for
the indicator for the indicator function
of
set ft but if you're not familiar with
it it's okay
now we want to look at greedy algorithm
of course greedy algorithm is very
intuitive but it's good too I always
like to get to an algorithm from the
optimality condition because after all
whatever algorithm you have you want to
compare the objective of that algorithm
to the optimal solution so let's see
what the optimal solution is in the
first place and see how how you can
watch the algorithm should do to be able
to get something close to optimal so
here's the dual again just convenience
the optimality condition the primal dual
optimal condition is this so a pair of
primal and dual variables so X is our
primal wise or dual variable or optimal
order this is an optimal primal dual
pair if and only if your Y is the slope
of your function is the gradient of
function at the sum of the optimal
primal and then the X is the optimal X's
are the maximizes of these linear
functionals over ft where the linear
functional is defined by the dual
variable y star
so is the optimality condition up there
again and let's look at greedy alright
so what does the greedy algorithm do at
time T you give the greedy algorithm F T
and it should assign a value to XT in
order to distinguish between the generic
variable names and the one assigned by
the algorithm I just use hat for this
greedy algorithm alright so yeah what
what the greedy algorithm does it
assigns the primal XT as the Maximizer
of a linear functional but the greedy
algorithm doesn't have access to the
optimal dual variable so it just keeps
an estimate of the dual variable and the
way it updates the dual variable is but
once the primal assignment was made the
dual variables updated by setting it as
a gradient of SCI evaluated at the
current some of your points so if you
just compare that to the optimality
condition you see that it's very similar
doing difference big difference is that
you don't know what's going to be a sign
in the future so you have only the sum
from 1 to T right and sum from 1 to M
and here you have some estimate of to a
variable not the actual optimum
and again another viewpoint of the
greedy algorithm would be something like
this so this is more formal legend of
I've written here I call a sequential
greedy algorithm for reasons that become
clear in a second it has an estimate of
dual variable at time one sets that
estimate to be the grain of Saia at zero
and then so basically if this is your
size function look at this loop of size
0 and then once the f1 comes it says X
fun as a Maximizer of this linear upper
bound on your function over the FT and
once that assignment and makes an
assignment x1 once the assignment was
made it goes on again finds the linear
upper bound over the concave function
which is given by the slope of function
at this point and then assigns x2 as a
Maximizer of that linear upper bound and
so forth
so this is basically Frank wolf
algorithm by the coordinate version of
Francophile rhythm where you to each
coordinate you apply only one step of
Frank wolf average now from the dual
point of view you could have also
suicide so this is the same thing on the
port the differences that are here I've
plotted the derivative of sy and the
assignments are being made and the voice
and X's are being updated but you can
also
by you can also look in the dual update
is always this you put once you make
your primal assignment you put Y as YT
plus 1 to be the gradient of SCI add the
current sum there shouldn't be no a here
that's knowing and but you can also
rewrite it in a way that makes it makes
the connection into the regret setting
you can write your dual update as
choosing your y 1/2 of T plus 1 as the
minimizer of this individual by the and
this comes by the properties of the
conjugate function and now if you look
at it this is basically follow the
regular rise leader with this specific
regularization minus the conjugate
function and these guys are basically
the gradients of these support functions
so you remember we define the support
function to be ya
so in this because of the fact that XT
is actually the the Maximizer of this by
the definition of the algorithm XT
becomes actually
this now this is not really gradients to
stop reading but I don't want to go into
the definition sorry so if you want a
map it to that regret setting basically
you lost that I said adversely gives you
a loss is just that
support function 4ft
any question
so now you may ask why do you want to
just smack you why do you want to
maximize the linear upper bound on your
function in a coordinate fashion when
you can just maximize the function
coordinate wise so that's that gives you
some other version of greedy algorithm
it's called that the simultaneous greedy
algorithm the reason I call it
simultaneous because if you're right in
the primal-dual format its equivalent of
updating the primal and dual
simultaneously together by solving a min
max problem rather than updating them
sequentially so this is basically
accordion maximization problem one by
one when a new Ft comes you put
corresponding X T as the Maximizer of
this guy these are the things you
already assign and this is a new thing
you want to assign and for this
algorithm I used Tod and just in order
to differentiate between the variables
assigned by the algorithm and the
generic optimization variables that we
have and I know in terms of this picture
is kind of summarize what's going on
here you make an assignment to X and y
kind of simultaneously here and Y and
this plot is the gradient of soil
derivatives I the Y is following the
derivative of psy at the current point
so now this connects something that
lorenzo mentioned and
which is the four forward Euler and and
the backward Euler method so if you
remember Lauren's talk mention that if
you want to discretize that continuous
optimization that he had you can do a
forward or backward Euler where
so maybe if you're this optimist you at
this point you you want to find an up an
update to get to you prime you can move
so for that for his minimization problem
you can move in the negative direction
of the gradient at you
so that was according to the forward
order discretization of is continuous
differential equation but you can also
do a backward Euler well not really you
can't really do it but theoretically you
can set your U prime to be a point that
satisfies this so u minus gradient of F
add u prime not you anymore so you call
this implicit because you know this you
your gradient is evaluated at a point
that you want to end up at so there are
similar things going on here and that is
the updates that are being done in this
this primal-dual update you can rewrite
that thing as having xt TD in our max of
X in F T
of this linear function
and YT TV is in arc mean a why of this
guy
Oh X&Y satisfy this condition if and
only if their sides fight this so you
see you see the XT healed it depends on
Y T TD yd TD depends on X ax till the
end you can rewrite this last one as yd
TD is the gradient of SCI
[Music]
so a gradient of sizes from 1 to T so
includes T itself this is in contrast to
the previous algorithm where YT plus 1
was gradient of psy at some from 1 to T
so it just doesn't have the T plus 1 it
and when you assign the XT you use the
gradient that was calculated previous
step a question
so now let's look at the analysis the
analysis also give us a more intuition
on two connections to the red setting
and so we wrote the greedy algorithm in
a problem of dwarf framework so let's
use the primal-dual value to actually
try to find a competetive ratio for the
greedy algorithm the primal value
achieved by the agree so they say the
simultaneous greedy algorithm the second
one I mentioned the primal value so I
applied to the only sum of the x's
signed by that algorithm and let's
define a dual value this way I put in
each one of those so the optimal dual
value is just one goal vector alright
what our algorithm produce M of M
actually was one of them so in each one
of those support functions I'm going to
put one of the in one of those whities
so in Sigma T I'm going to put Y T but
inside the conjugate I'm going to put
the last 12 variable and so in order to
get to come to ratio you can first start
from just bounding the duality gap so
remember that was a maximization problem
that you're trying to solve at the
beginning so we want to lower bound the
duality gap and so look at the
difference between the primal value
achieved minus the dual value so and by
PhD sick I mean the primal value
achieved by the sequential greedy
algorithm the frank worth 1 minus the
doll achieved by the the same algorithm
defined the same way so and the duality
gap for the first point is going to be
just the kind you get applied to the
last dual variable plus I of 0 that just
assume Phi of 0 is 0 so we don't have a
problem here and for the sequential
algorithm you have similar thing
with extra garbage I always say tease
off the title is no idea the extra
garbage actually has to do with the fact
that you were doing this or your dual
variable was lagging by one all the time
and so you pay a price so I'll go over
the proof of this really quick the proof
is very intuitive let's see if I can
pull this off and you can understand it
but so in order to so I want to prove
this duality gap bounds so the first one
that simultaneous algorithm so you can
first look at how much increment or how
much improvement your objective you make
at one step so at time T hama by
assigning xt how much I improved my
function so that's let's call this delta
p scene that's gonna be psy at this
point minus side the other point now
about concavity of psy this is gonna be
greater than equal to the gradient at
this point times the difference between
these two points so then this is just
but Desai
this is some from one to t minus one
this is some from 1 to T so the distance
between these two is exactly your XT you
added 260 here so this is greater than
equal to
with the left-hand side or the one in
the up is that Delta P scene one down
below
is an inner product
and you got that by concavity you don't
really exactly need concavity you only
need concavity in positive directions if
you assume that the points in the FT are
all out all of them are in the cone so
you only need concavity in the direction
of corn because if the fft is always a
subset of corn which actually this was
an assumption I forgot to mention all
the FTO subs of corn so say that I
support you're always adding to your
running sum of X DS and this is because
of the fact that the primal Bible was
assigned true maximizing this was taking
the art max actually this is actually
equal to the support function Sigma T
which is the soup of this over F T and
so it's now easy to get this you just
take the sum from T 1 to M these guys
are going to telescope and it's going to
give you P seem - sigh of 0 and then you
get this sum of Sigma T's on the right
hand side and a little bit of
manipulation you get this gap for the
second algorithm for the sequential
algorithm actually that was the first
island that was that Frank wolf one that
I mentioned or the forward Euler one the
the issue is that there is the issues
that your white tea was lagging all
right so whitey was the gradient
calculate that sum at this point not at
this point so what happens is that and
then the gradient at this point if you
for concave function you cannot lower
bound that function difference by X the
inner product with YT if because in that
case
that's gonna be your bye
this stop is your buy T and this is an
upper bound on the function difference
so what you need to do you need to look
at YT plus 1 that's the YT plus 1 is a
gradient at this point and that gives
you the same
right and but the problem was that the
algorithm wasn't actually taking the art
max width of the linear function of it
YT plus 1 and it was taking the R max
with Y T so if one related to the
support function you have to add and
subtract Y T to get the support function
and some extra garbage so this is a very
simple now this concept is that so if
you think of it so I had some from 1 to
t minus some saw at some from 1 to t
minus 1 if say this is the the red curve
here is the gradient or the derivative
of your function it does it's just the
area under this curve from here to here
and you're basically estimating an
integral in the sequential algorithm
you're picking these wise these slopes
so that you you're you're calculating an
integral using a Romanian sum when you
do Romanian some you can have an upper
bound or a lower bound on the integral
in the first algorithm you really have
an upper bound you're taking slopes at
these points all right but in your proof
what you really need is a lower bound so
in order to get that you have these
extra errors here that are exactly is
inner products alright while the
simultaneous algorithm is actually
taking getting a lower bound estimate on
the derivative of the function on the
integral of the derivative of the
function which is the function any
question
so I got a feeling that most people are
lost at this point so they just look at
a theorem to get even more lost so what
I gave you was a duality gap and I just
wanted to mention that duality gap is
really related to read in that for that
sequential algorithm as I mentioned what
we were doing in the dual was one of the
regularized leader with the
recognization equal to minus the
conjugate of psy so then that duality
gap that I had was actually in the proof
of regret is what you get before the
actual regret if you go in a little bit
further if you assume size Lipschitz
continuous or equivalently the conjugate
of saw is strongly comics with some
parity mu you do out the gap is going to
be this quantity and in regret the
freedom that people have is that the
regularizes they choose themselves so
the strong convexity parameter they put
it equal to a square root m manipulate
these things to Wow this is a this
basically minus regret in parentheses
manipulate these things to get a square
root M regret here the differences
that's in regularizer is not that much
of your choice you can't just put your
regular eyes or whatever strong comments
you want because you're in the business
of getting competitive ratio and not
just some duality gap and in that
business you can gave results such this
in order to turn that throughout the gap
in to come to ratio you can we need an
assumption first all right and that's
this called diminishing return
assumption the setting talked about
diminishing return and this is the same
diminishing return or what a vector
space it says that if your V is greater
than equal to if there's there's a V
that is greater than equal to there's a
u that is great
or equal to V with respect to your cone
now take the cone to be non-negative
water and that's going to be you is
element-wise greater than equal to V
then the gradient of Sai at U is going
to be less than or equal to gradient of
site V element wise and more general
terms with respect to the dual cone so
this is as basically a first order very
of writing diminishing return the zero
order one is going to be very similar to
this but in the vector space is gonna
say if you are the
as long as D is in your cone so here's
one connection to solve my dual arity so
once if you have such an assumption the
primal value achieved by say the
simultaneous algorithm is gonna be so
the lower bounded by someone with the
factor times the optimum and the
multiplicative factor defines on a
quantity which defines you on your
function it takes the value of the
conjugative function evaluate that the
gradient divided divided by the function
itself so this shows up in in a couple
of papers actually this one the many
papers shows up even if they are not
doing greedy are doing more advanced
algorithms but this quantity as I've
seen it multiple papers in their compte
ratios and it's these a little bit of
intuition the best I can do i can show
you a one-dimensional function so do you
remember the quantity is basically you
look at the ratio of the conjugate
devalue that the gradient divided by the
function look at the worst case of this
guy and this scales for a concave
function for a monotone concave function
the scales from minus 1/2 to 0 so the
best I can do is just give it one
dimension example this say the blue care
is the your function sigh at some point
you the value of side is going to be the
sigh of U 0 that's point u 0 the value
of conjugate evaluate that the
derivative is just a void intercept of
the tangent to the function at that
point with a negative sign so you're
looking at the ratio of these two that
I'm taking the worst case of that ratio
but for the first algorithm the
sequential algorithm you don't exactly
get a compte ratio you get some additive
stuff which has to do with
garbage or the Romanian some error
now you may ask okay when did when you
remembered in this assumption because we
got this we assume that we have this
diminishing return you may ask where did
you use that so the proof of this
algorithm is basically you use that
duality gap that I'll show you in
combination with these two facts that
only that come I can say only but they
come because of that diminishing return
that that to all quantities I define our
greater equality the optimal dual and
this is something that you can use
dimension we tend to show that and
there's some just facts that for the
monotone function alpha size greater
than or equal to minus 1 mountain
concave function and that results in a
company ratio of one half for greedy
Agra for non mortem fortune things are
kind of more complicated
but this this is all good and but I I
hope at least you get some intuition
about connections to regret but now
let's just focus on company vo a little
bit and first of all we had that
assumption that diminishing turn
assumption what are the functions that
satisfy those so Stephanie actually had
some of those in a lecture and in her
lecture slides so i'm not- wharton the
diminishing turn assumption any
separable concave function satisfies
that any twice differentiable function
whose Hessian is an element-wise non
positive again you saw that in a
Stephanie's lecture but we we went to
the trouble of these scones because we
may be inserting more than non-native
Orton so if you're interested in parts
definite corn for example log
determinant satisfies the diminishing
return assumption the trace of U to the
power of P for P from 0 to 1 satisfies
the assumption and so these these are
useful to people who are doing
experiment design and linear experiment
design and these objective may show up
so now okay so the first part is done
the second part in the last ten minutes
is that let me just ask any question you
know I'm doing very good job or a very
bad job in one of these so now let's
look at you know how one can move away
from greedy algorithm into some better
algorithms with better compte ratio in
order to see why you need to move away
from greedy algorithm so let's look at
this cartoonish example where you have
you got this function all right this is
your SCI and you're doing this online
optimization on it you apply in greedy
algorithm you will sign some value to X
and the corresponding dwell is going to
be the slope of your function at that
point which is 1 and then for X 2 the
same thing that the corresponding dual
is 1 the slope still 1 and all of a
sudden when you assign X 3 the slope is
0 all right but the greedy algorithm was
blind to this fact although it no side
beforehand
it wasn't predicting that the function
is plateauing so your return is going
down had had it had some more prediction
in it it may have been a little bit more
conservative at the beginning because it
knew what's going to happen in the
future
intuitively it would have been a little
bit better to apply greedy algorithm to
function like this ok your original
problem doesn't change your objective is
still is decide that plateaus but you
apply your greedy algorithm to the
smooth version of it now this has more
prediction built into it the slope is 1
at the beginning but is gradually
gradually comes down to 0 so when the
greedy algorithm is making assignments
it it's basically looking ahead in the
future and to the fact that the function
plateaus on your return becomes 0 at
some point
so can you
mathematically you have to if you want
to modify the greedy algorithm you can
go back and use a smooth version of your
original function in the greedy
algorithm alright your product your
original problem remains the same your
same your complete ratio is defined with
respect to that original problem but you
just apply the greedy algorithm to a
smooth version of it so mathematically
if you want to look at it they do all
and promise
the dual updates specifically in the
sequential algorithm and the primal-dual
updates in the simultaneous algorithm
are gonna be updated in a way that is
basically changing sigh - sighs now if
yours is satisfies the diminishing
return assumption you don't need to
start to satisfy it anymore
you get a complete ratio that is instead
of 1 over 1 minus alpha psy is 1 over 1
minus alpha sighs is which this looks
like a little bit more complicated you
know alpha site by itself is kind of
hard to true this is a little bit even
more complicated than that but
intuitively what this is doing is
basically measuring two things of course
you can go as smooth your function to
death
you can put zero you can put science
here that's the smooth function I know
but because you're doing compensate
ratio your size should have something to
do with your sigh and that's a
fundamental difference between you know
regret setting and this setting is that
you can't just go and put whatever
because this is is the regularizer yeah
the conjugate is the regularizer
you can't just put whatever regularizer
strongly convex regular that you want
you it should be related to your
original function side so when this
quantity is measuring both of them how
far you are from how smooth your size is
and how far is it from your original
function sigh so now the question is
what are some ideas for smoothing how
can I smooth my function so I come from
continuous optimization background so I
automatically look at what people do in
continuous optimization this idea of
I call net stripper smoothing but goes
back to bed circles pole yak or even
Mauro envelope which says that you know
take your function original function
side take its conjugate add some other
function to it some other concave
function and take the conjugate of the
entire thing and that's gonna give you
your size s so this is your choice this
something should choose if you choose it
to be zero all right the conjugate of a
conjugate of a concave function on their
model assumptions is gonna give you back
side so for example okay there was that
AdWords problem if you remember I use as
a motivation you can go and choose this
Phi Phi star I you use to be shifted
entropy so the shift and everything are
calculated in a way that you get a good
company ratio to get an and then apply
your greedy algorithm to the smooth
function is smooth with this specific
shifted entropy to get a controversial
one minus one over e which is the
optimal thing you can get alright so
within one hour we got to a 2007 weary
drive the 2007 result how many more
hours we need to get to the corner state
apart about probably five minutes
they're the same type of shifted entropy
can be used to actually again rewrite
URI drive results for online ALP because
at the end of the day AdWords is a
special case of online linear program
and a more general version of this will
give you optimal compte ratios for
online packing your piece and we drives
the algorithm in book binder and nor
from 2009
so the last five minutes I said some a
little bit more of a research stuff and
which is so you know how did I have you
come up with this well I looked at this
algorithm and reverse engineered it to
say oh this equivalent to is it is
equivalent of applying greedy to a
smooth version I mean and this is a
regularizer you have to use but the
question have you come up with these
things from scratch so it's not that
obvious so it would be good if there's a
mechanism to design smoothing so it's
automated mechanism that you can use to
design a smoothie and so you know we
realize that well one thing you can do
you can go back to your the company
ratio bound that you had and actually
say I want to find size that maximizes
this competitive race you're bound with
the condition that psy is vad är
function because I need that in my proof
so that's going to maximize a company
ratio bound for you and that's a convex
problem itself
the problem is that it's an infinite
dimensional problem you're you're
looking for
optimizing work space of functions and
even if you discretize it for some
general case it gives you exponentially
many constraints in the dimension but in
some special cases it's tractable and
you can solve it one is when you get
when you have a separable function so if
you have a separable function on the
non-negative Whorton meaning that you
can write it as a sum of sides applied
to the coordinates of you you can write
sai designs i you can design science in
the sense of going and optimizing your
compte ratio bound is an easier problem
and like this still this is a infinite
dimensional problem but we you can go
and discretize it and it can go so we
give it to CB X to solve it for you and
it basically reduces to designing the
smooth function for a scalar function
using the fact that usual function was a
separable function and using this you
can for example recover some algorithms
or results from there one orange chain
on AdWords with concave attends which is
a more general version of the average
problem where the return and is a more
complicated function is an example of
that I have here for you so my original
function is plotted in red so you
remember AdWords was very simple the
function was
piecewise linear function with a slope
of 1 then it plateaued so let's just add
one more one more piece to that
piecewise linear function so it has now
three pieces and I went and solve the
optimization problem we had for
optimizing the comte ratio bound and I
got this smooth function and then here I
I plotted the difference between the
conjugate of the smooth function and the
original function and it's something
like this so look at this and you
realize that this is not a concave
function so you could not have dried the
drive this smooth function by doing what
I called here the nest refer smoothing
which was adding another concave
function to your conjugate and then
taking the conjugate you could not have
dried that this is in that way plenty of
more examples but
precious so for the linear AdWords
problem what which algorithm do do
eventually get yeah yeah
like wishes so when you're automatically
and generating these footings is that it
looks it allows you I guess to get like
the value for the competitive ratio that
in the algorithm actually probably needs
the exact functions an hour so yes so
when we design it what we get is what
they smooth function that the algorithm
needs and it also gives us the optimal
compte ratio bound that we had so our
company ratio found was 1 over 1 minus
alpha the computation bound in that
theorem so maximizing that is equal to
minimizing the 1 minus is equivalent to
minimizing moments alpha so it gives you
that bound as well
again
[Applause]